[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
Robert Mellors testimony to Congress
devastated the Russia Gate hoax
nonetheless the partisan in fighting
continues but what about Russia gates
impact on geopolitics also is there a
new start in Ukraine can some insky find
away
[Music]
cross knocking some real news i'm joined
by my guest glenn DS and he is a
professor at the higher school of
economics as well as author of the decay
of western civilization and resurgence
of russia also we have Dimitri Baba
she's a political analyst and editor at
unisza me internet media project and in
Nicosia we cross to Alex Christopher oh
he's the director and writer for the
duran calm all right gentleman crosstalk
rules in effect that means you can jump
in anytime you want and i always
appreciate it
let's go to Alex and Nicosia Alex I'm
calling this program boomerang okay
in the wake of the of the Muller
testimony which was absolutely
devastating was actually painful to
watch and I have to admit I actually
felt a little sorry for him because he
was just a prop in somebody else's game
and that was the investigators that are
being investigated right now where do we
stand in all this and I want to talk
later about its geopolitical impact go
ahead Alex and Nicosia yeah I mean well
I think the big revelation Peter is that
we've had two three years not of the
Mueller investigation and we didn't have
the Mueller report and we didn't even
have the Mueller statement a couple of
weeks ago what we had was the Andrew
Weissman investigation the Andrew
Weissman report and a statement that was
most likely penned by Andrew Weissman
and Andrew Wiseman had a team of around
1718 Democrat partisan lawyers people
that were working for Hillary Clinton
people that worked for the Clinton
Foundation people that represented
Hillary Clinton in court and when
Mueller was presented with all of these
facts as to who was on the team
supposedly investigating Trump what did
Mueller say a hundred and ninety eight
times it's not in my purview hmm I don't
know he didn't know about the steel
dossier I didn't know about fusion GPS
he didn't know about Glenn Simpson he
didn't know about anything well Alex I
think also one very important thing he
didn't understand considering he used to
be he used to run the FBI was a
prosecutor that he didn't understand the
presumption of innocence he admitted it
publicly is that and you had mainstream
media the left media talking about no
one's above the law but in his testimony
he said there's an
paraphrasing there's an exception it's
Donald Trump so even he turned the
entire concept of presumption of
innocence on its head glenn let me go to
you one of the interesting things that's
happened all during this we all know
that Trump is a candidate in 2016 one
and to better relations with Russia now
obviously that has not happened I came
across an op-ed in the New York Times
published a couple days ago
what's America's winning hand if Russia
plays the China card something we've
been talking about for over 10 years on
this program okay
the two adversaries are growing closer
posing a strategic challenge to the
United States this is the most important
part of the article China not Russia
represents by far the greatest challenge
to American objectives over the long
term that means President Trump is
correct to try to establish a sounder
relationship with Russia and to peel it
away from China it goes on editorial
pages suddenly crawl crawl out from
under a rock for the last four or five
ten years anyone that had any sense knew
this was happening but it's a discovery
for the New York Times I'm sure to talk
to Henry Kissinger cuz he met with Trump
early on and that was his advice as well
as Bannon to fix some of the mistakes
done in the 90s and indeed if you look
back in the 1990s that was recognized as
being one of the possible consequences
by expanding NATO without including
Russia that will be alienated and slowly
drift towards China Iran and other
countries in the East and you know the
Primakov doctrine and the rest now I
you could have however excuse the New
York Times to some extent for for a
while because Russia was very much
committed ever since Gorbachev to
integrate into this greater Europe a
common European home so for a while they
used the China card a bit to elevate
their own market value if you want but
that was only to a certain extent
because they they really want to you
know find some advantages in the
relationship they didn't want
integration what they wanted was
submission is what they wanted and
something that Russia refused to do yeah
circa 2000 well it's just amazing though
the New York Times writes Trump is right
to make a more sound relationship with
Russia his just expenses more than 100
Russian diplomats you know he provided
lethal weapons to Ukraine you know these
weapons are killing thousands of people
who speak the same languages us who went
to the same school watch the same
television who are actually us and that
is more sound relationship with Russia
give me a break on the mujer you know
what is amazing is that Rush Limbaugh is
is criticizing him for the lack of
preparedness well no wonder you are
investigating something that never
happened
no wonder not prepared so and you have
to compile a four hundred forty eight
eight page report on that it was
pathetic you know they asked him did you
meet Christopher Steele I won't answer
Kay it's like it's like someone has been
it's been questioned by the judges did
the guy beat you by his boots yes
what color were the boots I'm not going
to answer that question did you actually
meet the guy I'm not going to answer
that question
did he beat you yes yeah I was just
gonna say that there was some you know
pending delusions here Moscow that
perhaps they would gradually be
integrated with the West you know be
part of this greater year but that all
fell apart in 2014 when the West back to
ku and that's when they very much
switched abandoned this greater Europe
and went for greater Eurasian state so
now they're fully integrating well
cooperating with China instead so this
it's no longer you know this marriage of
convenience or simply let me go back to
Alex and Nicosia Alex I mean this is the
thing that we've discussed it at length
on this program is that the Republicans
and the Democrats obviously differ on
what Russia gate means okay but one
thing they do not differ on and it no
evidence has been presented to us and
I'm talking about not the leaks but I'm
not the Hat
of the of the DNC but leaks from the DNC
and and so and all these other related
issues here
there's no one with inquiring minds
probably beyond us in consortium
news.com and a few other people that
would look at this this claim of
systemic meddling it's just not there
but no one wants to discuss it and
that's the only consensus they have
regarding this hoax go ahead Alex I
agree with you and I think during the
the Mueller testimony while it answered
a lot of questions or it revealed a lot
I think there's still now even more
questions diagraph as to how this thing
started and how this thing moved along
and it moved into this from from what
should have been counterintelligence
investigation moved into a criminal
probe of a US president but Peter I
think it goes deeper and going back to
the New York Times article you know that
this this hit to a point where you had I
think it was clapper and correct me if
I'm wrong wasn't it clapper that at one
point in time I believe last year called
Russians not the Kremlin not Putin said
Russians are and I'm paraphrasing are
liars or are devious they're genetically
trusted right they're genetically
predisposed to it yes exactly thank you
thank you so I mean this is this entire
three years of demonization while you
know you could say that the truth went
out as far as you know Trump Russia
collusion the other day the deep state
and the mainstream media have scored a
victory in that they have demonized
Russia to the point where I can't see
any chance I agree
I bring us the blurring Russia away from
China Glenn I agree I mean to repair
this kind of this relationship where it
could be I think where it should be will
take a generation there this is really a
very challenging time for the United
States because yeah China is now leaping
ahead of them what they really need to
do strategically is to find a way of
appealing of Russia and yeah that you
can't have that anymore now because even
though they split the Democrats and
Republicans in terms of whether or not
you know Trump was conspiring with the
crime
they seem to reach a consensus that yes
yeah well the Russians meddled in the
election even though there's no evidence
and so I would like they hopefully did
it could come out now because they're
gonna do a bit of an investigation
especially Democrats want the
Republicans want to find out how did
this whole thing can the entire
establishment in both parties and the
media and Hollywood give you can they
all collectively say we got it wrong
deema them they can't do that this is
because you know what this this sense of
vendetta is in their genetic code it's
not the Russians in their genetic code
Azure are liars and cheats but this
ideology and it's very very core cannot
correct itself
well I'm skeptic about the genetic codes
but about the ideology I'm not skeptical
because it reminds me of our Soviet
communist ideology persons can be wrong
ideology can never be wrong that's the
same attitude okay
Muller he was a hero for three years now
suddenly album you were stopped to be
our muir and he's been criticized
Russians got to him problem was leave
how far this is go stop to be our muir
in the Wall Street Journal for the New
York Times who actually lionized him
lion ice cream why because he was not
prepared and he was not prepared because
he didn't write it because he
investigated something that never
happened somebody else investigated
something you know talking about Russia
Russia u.s. relationship I think it
started way before 2014 I mean all of my
college career since 1989 the United
States you know the war in Chechnya the
United States let's put it you know
right they were on the side of the
rebels the media was 100% on the side of
the rebels the conflicts between Russia
and former republics of the Soviet Union
you know the expansion of NATO actually
Putin first voiced his protest in 2007
seven years before 2014 he has been
warning you know he has been actually a
big security conference exactly the
Munich Security Conference and
did well for the Russian people now to
believe you know the American government
it will indeed take a generation but
with the Russian elite it's a different
situation because these people still
want to believe in kind good West they
invested in it too much and that's a big
problem on that we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on some
real news day welcome back to crosstalk
where all things are considered on Peter
level to remind you were discussing some
real news
[Music]
okay let's go back to Nicosia Alex it
should turn our attention to Ukraine
Solinsky was a few months ago elected
president he as an independent nominally
speaking really trounced poroshenko his
party a week ago won a clear victory in
the in the Rada in the parliament he has
at least nominally speaking he has a
mandate here I guess that we all have to
wonder what the Europe's position is in
the u.s. position is in Canada because
they are still power brokers inside of
Ukrainian politics and it was the people
that voted for Zielinski so I would say
the second project that they had for
Ukraine is in tatters where do we go
from here go ahead Alex we are five
years removed from the Maidan coup
instigated by the Obama administration
Geoffrey Pyatt Victoria Nuland and here
we are now with szalinski he has a
mandate I think that mandate is to
figure things out
with the East Ukraine to figure figure
things out with the dom vas to figure
things out with russia and as far as
Europe goes Peter you have a new
European leadership it is perhaps
actually I would say I'm very confident
that it is worse than the leadership we
had before yeah we've got two failed
German Defense Minister now running the
show we got a failed IMF chief now
running the money stream and I don't
think Europe is in a position to do
anything I don't think you're a boss to
deal with Ukraine I think that's become
blatantly obvious they're tired of
Ukraine they don't want to deal with it
so I think we're looking at a United
States and that United States is not
headed by Obama it is headed by Trump
and Trump knows very well that Ukraine
was meddling in the elections to get
Hillary Clinton into the Oval Office and
I think Trump doesn't have much of an
appetite to deal with Ukraine so if
there's anybody in the United States
escort that's going to spoil the the rep
Rush mode with Ukraine and Russia I
think you're going to be looking at the
neo cons vault in Pompeo max boots and
these guys and Glenn there's an
interesting parallel here because you
have Trump
all during his administration in one
form or another fighting the deep state
and Sowinski actually is fighting the
deep state in his own country as well
because a lot of the poroshenko people
are still around and our have their
hands on the levers of power for now
does he his mandate give him enough
strength to really start pushing things
through because irrespective of what he
thinks about Russia relations with
Russia he knows it doesn't having bad
relations doesn't help Ukraine
definitely and well he has unprecedented
power in Ukraine because they always had
two parties or two sides and very
fragile leadership but now it's very
different like he Solinsky holds
parliament he has the presidency
obviously and the opposition is weak on
one hand you've got the the radical
nationalists which were backed by the
West who are now marginalized the
poroshenko's and and then you have the
opposition bloc which much more
favorable to better relations with
Russia but they've been purged over the
last five years so you have a difficult
situation now and so well he has all the
power to do what he was elected to do
but yeah as you mention much like Trump
reminded of Milton Friedman's tyranny or
status quo because you can have
bureaucrats politicians and
beneficiaries who have a certain
interest to me in any way outspoken NGOs
setting their own red lines for wedges
szalinski should and shouldn't do in
western back NGOs by the way yeah of
course is still very much dependent on
the United States though and the u.s.
driven IMF on all this loan so this no
matter what is want to do in foreign
policy and especially with Russia he's
gonna have to I guess get okay from the
Americans and I do agree that United
States especially Trump might not you
know view Ukraine as favorable as his
predecessor however there is there is
more or less a recognition that would be
in the strategic interest of the u.s. to
have a clean break between Russia and
Ukraine essentially separate completely
and have it aligned more with the West
and if you end it conflict in Donbass
that little you know spoil the war might
be lost so it is quite possible that
it's not in
as interest necessarily - for Ukraine
and Russia to solve this differences and
that's that's their modus operandi it
always is here Dima
Sowinski has opportunities here at least
on paper at least according to law is he
but will he be bold enough because I in
the past I kind of scoffed at his idea
of being chaperoned in meeting with
Putin now I think maybe that's not a bad
idea cuz that's the icebreaker that's
what how you get things started
where's Olinsky doesn't look like he's
completely selling out and and he he
feels that he has some have supported
broad because he certainly has it at
homes but there's no doubt about that
and that would be a way for a segue
forward for Ukraine and Russia to start
talking normally to each other well I'm
afraid I'm going to be the most
pessimistic person here because
Yanukovych also had popular mandate he
won the election in 2010 no one disputed
it this time Russia disputes it because
our observers were not allowed because
there were five years of anti-russian
terror in the country now it's a
different thing you know this election
is slightly disputed but but you know
the alien skis aid is saying oh mr.
Solinsky mr. president he's not going to
meet Putin alone he's going to have
adults you know with him who will tell
him how to solve the problem well we
know who the adults are right and and
the suggestions from the Western press
what salience we should do and what he
is already doing the main thing is to
start sailing land to foreign customers
this is something that even poroshenko
balked at and this is exactly what I am
f once also start privatizing utilities
you're absolutely right I mean selling
out Ukraine and that's always been part
of the engineer but there's one thing
they have to resolve is the energy
relationship because we have Nord Stream
two coming online very soon we have the
southern pipeline as well
I mean Ukraine understands he has this
very small window but right now in the
end of the
year to to resolve some energy issues
with Russia or Ukraine will be
completely shut out of the European
market you know first you have an
avalanche of lies in the European media
in the American media they all keep
saying that Russia cart supplies of gas
to Europe in 2009 and that for that
reason you know gospel may not get the
permission you know from from the
European Union to Tory how is that even
logical when they want to have a
pipeline from Russia to Germany and
Russia taken for that which is paying
and building it basically alone well
that the truth is in 2009 the Ukrainians
did not pay for the gas they did not pay
their debts and when Russia continued
pumping gas and they stopped paying the
Ukrainians took the gas siphon it off at
at the moment the Ukrainian president
Yushchenko did not talk to the ukrainian
prime minister Tymoshenko that's why she
signed this agreement with with putin
and later on she was put in jail boring
and the West was on her side even though
showed me a country where the Prime
Minister is not talking to the president
signs a deal with another country right
and this is not just two persons he is
very important you know on Ukraine's
relationship with the United States
zillions he is doing something that the
West wanted him to do he is firing would
Sanko the prosecutor general why would
Sanko had a terrible quarrel with the US
ambassador yovanovich and she backed
Obama openly so there was this story and
the other story I just loved it in the
New York Times they're writing jellinsky
should keep his distance from Igor
kolomoisky the ariga oolagah who is now
accused of looting a bank just that well
in 2014 when kolomoiskiy was providing
logistics for the operation of ukrainian
troops against Donbass they were fine
with him even though he was looting the
bank at that moment and now they
suddenly right keep away from this bad
man he has muted a bastard media and
establishment have short memories they
may be the condition of modernity I know
what it is in mine
this ideology makes them forgetful here
Alex but having said that I'm glad Dima
putting his two cents of pessimism
because it's probably it's warranted in
many ways this after all is Ukraine Alex
but Zielinski has a mandate a popular
mandate there's no doubt about that he
has a parliament now it seems to me it's
gonna be just we're gonna have to
determine how a droid he is because he's
dealing with a lot of sharks around him
I'm glad Dima brought up called the
moisty because it's still a state
controlled by oligarchs he has a tough
path ahead but he's our he's dotted all
the i's and cross the t's to get this
started go ahead Alex yeah solinsky's
big problem is definitely the deep state
within his own country I think there's
and there's no doubt about it the Olek
arcs and these people that's the that
are going to try to derail any efforts
that he puts forth to mend ties with
Donbass and with Russia and I really
think that the European Union in the
United States are just don't they just
don't have the appetite to deal with
Ukraine I just don't see it I also think
that going into the elections in the US
I think Ukraine is going to be a very
sensitive topic especially your body see
exactly if we see Biden as a candidate
for the Democrats I think if that
happens I think there's not going to be
much talk about Ukraine even though
Trump may actually bring Ukraine up more
than the left establishment media would
like so I think that's a fact that we
have to watch closely you know balance
with me staying with you know I go back
to this New York Times editorial that I
read in the first part of the program I
mean if they really do want it and have
Trump better relations with Russia then
why don't you just drop Ukraine that's
one thing that would better relations
yeah well I mean I think we're one week
away Peter from seeing Rachel Maddow do
a segment as to why Trump's to blame for
pushing Russia into the arms of China
so I mean we've crunched with Trump
derangement syndrome and any big
response there's no doubt about that
all right 40 seconds to finish it so go
ahead ya know
I I tend to agree I think that Solinsky
probably will have to clear out all the
old guard who's already in this
administration when he needs but I think
what he needs to do we have to worry
about the deep state obviously but his
greatest challenge is to get the
oligarchs out of out of power politics
okay
that's what Putin did then in and that
is the pet path that Ukraine should have
taken is they get this money out of
politics for up to me being a bit of an
optimist I would see this compare him to
Putin like Putin he came to power with
the help of certain oligarchs but as
soon as he was in power he went after
them because he said he was going to
clean out the Russian system of this
corrupt oligarchs when which is when
they were left for London in the u.s. of
course but it is possible that Solinsky
simply being you know getting order and
again my guest here in Moscow and in
Nicosia and thanks for viewers for
watching us here arty see you next time
and remember crosstalk roles
you
[Music]